مساء الخير عشان نفهم علاقه
الاسلام الحكومه
الامريكيه بمعناها الكبير لازم نفهم تاريخ
علاقه الاسلام مع الولايات المتحده وطبيعه
هذه العلاقه منذ انشاء هذه الامبراطوريه
العظيمه من 1700 وشويه نهايه 1700 وشيه
الحقيقه ان العلاقه دي من اللحظات الاولى
لتاسيس الامبراطوريه الامريكيه وهي علاقه
ملتبس يعني تراوحت تقريبا كده ما بين
العداء الشديد للاسلام لاسباب نتكلم فيها
والى من الاعداء الشديد الى التعاطف مش من
قبيل الحب ولا الاعجاب ولكن من قبيل اظهار
التسامح فكان الغالب على الاباء المؤسسين
للولايات المتحده فكره خلاصتها ان اللي
يظهر تسامحه مع الاسلام او المحمديين كما
كانوا يسمون المسلمين وقتها معناه انه
بيظهر اكبر قدر ممكن من التسامح اللي
تسامح مع المحمديين معناه انه يتسامح مع
كل اطياف وكل اصحاب الديانات الاخرى اذا
حبينا نستعرض على سبيل
المثال علاقه الاباء المؤسسين يعني
الرؤساء الاوين الامريكان الرؤساء
الامريكان الاوائل بالاسلام هنجد انه جورج
واشنطون الرئيس الاول كانت علاقته علاقه
نظريه وكان بيغلب عليها الرغبه في اظهار
سامح مع كل الاديان حتى المحمد مره ثانيه
ليس حبا في الاسلام ولكن اذا كنت انا
تتسامح مع المحمديين يبقى انا بتسامح مع
كل اصحاب الديانات والطوائف الاخرى بما
فيها الطوائف
الاقل التي لم تكن تحضى باهتمام او
باهتمام منهم المسلمين وبالمناسبه كذلك
اليهود في وقتها وبعض الطوائف المسيحيه
مثل
الكاثوليكيه اظهر ازهر جورج رغبته او
تسامحه مع المسلمين في عبارات مختلفه منه
مثلا انه عبر عن رغبته انه مستعد يستقبل
العمال من كل الديانات ومن كل الطائف حتى
المحمديين في بلدته اذا كانوا عمالا
جيدين عبر عن رغبته في اعفاء المحمديين من
دفع الضرائب اللي كانت مفروضه في ولايه
فيرجينيا لبناء الكنائس باعتبارهم ان هم
مسلمين التعاطف النظري على الاقل لجورج
واشنطن بيرجع لسببين السبب اللي انا قلته
لحضراتكم اظهار اكبر قدر ممكن من التسامح
حتى تنجح التجربه الامريكيه والسبب الثاني
انه كان لدى جورج واشنطن اللي كان بيملك
1774 عبد بيدفع عنهم الضرائب خادمتين او
عبدت مسلمتين فاطمه الاولى فاطمه الكبيره
وفاطمه الصغيره ويبدو ان علاقته بهتين
الخادمتين كان احد اسباب تعاطفه ولو كان
نظريا مع المسلمين بقول نظري لانه كل
الكلام اللي كان كان بيقول جورج واشنطن لم
يكن يعلم وقته على وجه اليقين انه عنده
عشرات الالاف من المسلمين اللي دخلوا
امريكا منذ القرن ال 16 ولكن معظمهم كان
عبيدا وبالمناسبه وجود المسلمين كعبيد
بالدرجه الاولى منذ منذ القرن ال 16 كان
احد اسباب تهميش الوجود المسلمين في
الولايات المتحده المسلمين ظلوا لفتره
طويله على هامش التجربه الامريكيه ومش جزء
منها الرئيس اني جون ادامز اللي هو جاه
بعد جورج واشنطن كان موقفه مختلف لانه كان
واضح العداء
لمسلمين وكان ليه موقف مت متشدد ووصف
الرسول الكريم عليه الصلاه والسلام بانه
زي نابليون شخص مهوس بالحرب ويرغب دائما
في العدوان والعداء على الاخرين استمر هذا
التعبير عن العداء بصوره اوضح على لسان
ابن انه جون كوينزي ادامز اللي هو الرئيس
السدس للولايات المتحده وده كان ليه موقف
شديد العداء للاسلام وللمسلمين وكتب عده
مقالات بعد ما ترك البيت الابيض من تقريبا
الفتره من
1825 ل 1829 كتب مقالات بيحلل فيها الحرب
الروسيه التركيه اللي كانوا بيرابو من
بعيد وكان وقتها وهو بيحلل اداها بعد ديني
وراى ان المشكله كلها ليست بس في
العثمانيين كعثمان او الاتراك ولكن في
كونهم مسلمين وكتب كلام شديد القسوه وشديد
العدائيه عن الرسول الكريم وعن الاسلام
وكان من بين ما كتب
مثلا في مقالاته اللي ما زالت منشوره
ويمكن الرجوع اليها في صدد تحليل الحرب
الروسيه التركيه انه في القرن السابع
الميلادي ظهر عربي متجول من سلاله هاجر
المصريه جمع بين العبقر
وطاقه خارقه من التعصب والاحتيال واعلن
نفسه رسولا من السماء ونشر الخراب في رقعه
واسعه من الارض وفي موضع ثاني بيقول انه
جوهر العقيده يقصد العق يقصد العقيده
الاسلاميه هو العنف والشهوه واعلاء
الوحشيه على الجانب الروحي في الطبيعه
البشريه على عكس
المسيحيه وفي مواضع اخرى اعتبر ان السلام
لن يحل ابدا طالما بقى تعليم هذا الرجل
موجود على وجه الارض وقال انه من تصاريف
القدر او من حكم الله سبحانه وتعالى انه
تنتصر هذه العقيده الوحشيه على العقيده
الوديعه للمسيح عليه السلام كان دائما
مصور اي حرب يكون طرف فيها المسلمين على
انها حرب
دينيه موقف جون كوينزي ادمز وموقف ابوه
الحقيقه نقدر نفهمهم ببساطه لما نعرف انه
الرئيس الام امريكي اللي هو ابوه جون ادمز
ثم ابنه لاحقا الرئيس السادس انه كانوا ان
ابوه كان اقتنى اول طبعه للقران الكريم
طبعت في الولايات المتحده كانت اظن سنه
1800 1800 هو اشتر سنه سنه 1806 وهو
اشترها في نفس العام وهي طبعا مشوشه
ومليئه بالاخطاء والاساءات للاسلام
وللمسلمين والقران الكريم الرجل تشبع بهذه
التعليم فضلا عن تعصبه السابق فكان له
موقف متشدد الكلام ده يختلف على يختلف
كتير عن موقف الرئيس الثالث للولايات
المتحده توماس جيفرسون اللي اللي كان واخد
موقف متسامح مع كل الاديان ومع المسلمين
على وجه
التحديد بس هذا الموقف مره ثانيه لم يكن
حبا في الاسلام كاسم ولكن لان هو كان رجل
راغب في ان يتسع تتسع الامبراطوريه
الجديده لكل الاديان وكان طالب كتب اكثر
من
مره عند اعداد وثيقه الاستقلال للولايات
المتحده 1776 الا يتم
حرمان اي صاحب دين من حقوق المدنيه على
اساس الدين وما زالت موجوده بخط ايده في
مكتبه الكونجرس عباره بتقول يجب ان يحرم
المحمديين واليهود من حقوقهم المدنيه على
اساس الدين والعباره دي كان واخدها مصر
لانه كان راجل واسع الاطلاع من الفيلسوف
البريطاني جون لوك اللي كتب نفس العباره
تقريبا وهو نسخها بايده وحاول تطبيقها
بالمناسبه ما اختصرت كلام جيفرسون على
الكلام النظري بس ولا مطالبته بانه
المسلمين يحصلوا على حقوقهم المدنيه كامله
في وقت كان معظم الامريكان متاثرين
[موسيقى]
باساتذة المسلمين في كتب كثيره من كتابات
الاوروبيين عن المسلمين لكن هو حاول يطبق
ده فعليا فلما اندلعت الحرب ما بين
الولايات المتحده وما سمي بالقرصنه
المسلمين في ليبيا والجزائر
وتونس كثير من السياسيين ومنهم جون ادمز
اللي كان بعد ما خرج من البيت الابيض اصر
يعتبرها حرب ما بين الاسلام والمسيحيه
ورفض هذا تماما رغم انه خد قرار الحرب
واصر ان دي مجرد حرب اقتصاديه وسياسيه
بحته وكان حتى في خطاباته الى هذه الدول
بيضغط على النقطه دي نحن نحترم دينكم
والمساله لا تعدو ان تكون خلافا على
المصالح والاولويات ولما استقبل ودي كانت
اول حرب خارجيه للولايات المتحده يعني اول
حرب خارجيه بتاخدها الولايات المتحده خارج
ارضها كانت ضد مسلمين ولما استقبل في سنه
1805 اول دبلوماسي مسلم هو سفير تونس سنه
1805 اصر التعبير عن الاحترام لدينه ان
يجعل وجب الغزاء بدل من الظهر يخليها بعد
ما غيب الشمس يعني تبقى افطار افطار رمضان
احتراما
لدينه الحقيقه لما نتتبع برضو موقف
جيفرسون اللي كان عبر باكثر من طريقه عن
احترامه للاسلام ورغبته
في احترام المسلمين وحقوقهم هنرجع مره
تانيه لما قراه جيفرسون
فكان نقدر نتتبع ببساطه انه سنه
1765 اشترى تركان القران للمستشرق
البريطاني جورج سيل وكانت اكثر دقه واكثر
انصافا خاصه ان هي كانت مشفوعه او معاها
حوالي 200 صفحه عن دين الاسلام وعن
عبادتهم وعن عقائدهم
و يعني احاديث الرسول الكريم فكان قرات
لهذه الترجمه لجورج سيل جعلته اكثر تسامحا
مع الاسلام والمسلمين على
عكس سابق جون ادامز اجمالا المواقف
الكبيره والمتشدد ما بين التسامح وما بين
التعصب بين الرؤساء الامريكان الاوائل
اختلفت كتير بعد كده مع الرؤساء اللي
جاؤوا في العصر الحديث ابتداء من بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اللي خدوا موقف
مختلف كتير مع الاسلام والمسلمين لكن ده
يكون موضوع لحلقه اخرى ان شاء الله
واشكركم الى لقاء اخر